The Wall Street Journal recently ran a
story headlined, "The New Copycats: How
Facebook Squashes Competition From
Startups". Basically, the tech giants can
buy out any startup they want or
aggressively imitate them and drive them
out of business.
How alarming should we find this? Well,
judging by the growing number of voices
calling for regulating big tech, from
Tucker Carlson to Elizabeth Warren, I
think I'm supposed to be pretty alarmed.
But what is the public policy problem
here? Acquisition is typically a good
thing for the startups themselves, and
the startup sector is still pretty
vibrant. The main concern seems to be
whether the market dominance of these
tech giants is a bad thing. It's tough to
make that case from a consumer welfare
standpoint, since most of these products
are free. Plus, these companies are
certainly acting as if their dominance
is tenuous, given how closely they track
their potential competitors. In other
words, the sheer size of big tech
shouldn't concern us too much. Longer
term, it's their control of big data that
is likely to be where the antitrust
regulatory battle rages.
To learn more about my take on regulating big tech,
check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you
want our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.